it's taken 1275 days since Britain voted
to leave the EU to get this the ice of
the right 358 the nose to the left
234 a government win on brexit four
attempts and two general elections later
MPs have finally approved a brexit
blueprint this bill learns the emphatic
lesson of the last Parliament unlike
members opposite and rejects any further
delay that we depart from the EU on the
31st of January at that point breaks it
will be done it will be over this is the
time when we move on and discard the old
labels of leave and remain about the
very word seem tired to me a lot will
change now and quickly with that a
hundred and twenty four majority the
opposition are at a stroke powerless in
the Commons just as the government
begins a far-reaching programme of
social economic and political change and
some are asking what is the point of the
Labour Party now does it matter that six
Labour MPs rebelled against the
leadership to support Boris Johnson's
brexit deal does it matter how potential
successors to Jeremy Corbyn voted today
it really matters and I would have loved
to have seen one of those leadership
contenders or anyone thinking of it come
through the lobby with me today and do
the right thing by the people we
represent another admitted the brexit
deal he voted for today makes him sad I
mean because I hope I'll be happier than
I am now in that the government amends
this bill aligned with labour party
policy in terms of environment
rights workers rights and the like but
when we leave I think I'll be sad
because of the scale damaged this
wrecked on labor conservatives who voted
remain in 2016 are finding consolations
one of the reasons politics has been
miserable for the last three years is
that we all got stuck each of us has
defined each other as levers or
remainders as though that's all that
matters in politics as a country we've
absolutely get to beyond that we've got
to stop looking back mr. 2016 and start
looking forward Boris Johnson's triumphs
last Thursday means that he has
withdrawn pre-election concessions
offered to Labour MPs
these include Clause 30 removing MPs say
over whether or not to extend the
transition period also a raised is
Clause 31 which gave MPs a say over
future EU negotiations also out tolls 34
which gave guarantees on workers rights
and clause 37 a promise to protect
unaccompanied children seeking asylum
although the government insists they
remain committed to this objective by
other means Boris Johnson drives away
for Christmas knowing he doesn't really
need to worry about the Commons anymore
the brexit argument has finally been
settled in his favor Sam Cote Sky News